these are the photos shared by Cory
Monteith's mother and McGregor as part
of a heartfelt tribute to her late sons
Glee co-star Naya Rivera
Maya's body was discovered at
California's Lake Piru on Monday
concluding a five-day search following
her disappearance during a boating trip
with her four-year-old son Josie I love
you
[Music]
eerily Rivera's body was found on what
was the seventh anniversary of
Monteith's untimely death
[Music]
on Tuesday Cory's mom expressed the pain
she's feeling over nya's death
captioning this photo montage of her son
with the 33 year old in part quote for
the last seven years the 13th of July
has shattered our hearts beyond repair
there aren't enough words to describe
the pain we're feeling we are truly
heartbroken
the single mom continued by remembering
all the ways Cory admired Naya writing
quote Cory truly adored you he was in
awe of your incredible talent the way
you gave everything you had to each
performance the slap and the auditorium
was one of his favorite stories to share
tell her to Santana everyone's gonna
know now because of you the whole school
already knows and you know what they do
that's just the school you idiot
everyone what are you talking about
McGregor even went on to call Rivera
family quote you once said koi was like
a member of your family you will always
be part of ours we'll carry you in our
hearts forever we miss you friends
reunited for eternity Monteith starred
as Finn Hudson on Glee until his death
on July 13th 2013 due to an accidental
overdose he was 31 at the time
you